With the release of the Karlov
Manor Murders set,
the mechanic,
which first appeared
in 2006 in
Time Spiral, received a
functional
update that
significantly strengthened it.
Let's take a look at the
rules update for the
Suspend mechanic
.  "Exile" is
a mechanic that
allows you to pay a
reduced cost for a
card, after which
it goes into
exile with several
time counters on
it.  At the beginning of
your
upkeep step, you may
remove one
time counter from
any number of your
cards in exile, and
when the last
counter disappears, you
may cast a spell for free
.  Any creatures
played this
way gain
haste.
Functional
update is actually
very simple.
Only two words are added to the rules text, but this
change strengthens a number of
decks, especially in the
Modern format.  These
two words—"you can.
"  The final part
of the description of "Exile"
now reads as follows.
When the last
time counter
is removed, you may
play this card
without paying its mana
cost.  While this
change is incredibly
small, it affects
two of the strongest
decks in Modern:
Mono-Red Bern
and Four-Color
Rhino.  Both of these
decks
use
powerful cards with the
Exile mechanic
, so let's
take a look at how exactly
they were affected.  For the
Four-Colored
Rhinos, the usual
game plan is to simply
use
the cascade to
play the key
card "Rumble of Footsteps
" and put
the Rhinos onto the battlefield
on turn three.  But
sometimes you just have
a copy of this card in your
starting hand and
just "banish"
it on the first turn.
Since Rhinos
are a very popular
deck, one of the
key
sideboard cards against them is
Raging Whirlwind.  This is a
two-mana red enchantment that has the following
ability: "
Whenever a player
casts a spell
without spending
mana, Raging
Whirlwind deals
five
damage to that player."  "
Storming Whirlwind" is
great against
incarnations and
free
spells
obtained through
cascade.  Of course, in both of
these cases, you could
simply not
cast
the spell to
avoid taking five
points of damage.  However,
with cards that have
Exile, you
never had that
choice.  The
Banishment rule read: "
When the last
time counter
is removed, cast
it without paying its mana
cost."  You were
forced to cast
spells,
whether
it was good or
bad for you.  So,
if you had
five lives left and there
was a "Storming
Whirlwind" on the table, unfortunately, this
meant big
trouble.    A
similar situation
arose with players
on mono-red
decks.  In the middle of
the game, if a player used a
mono-red
deck to pause
Rift Bolt, and their opponent
cast
Leyline of Sanctity on their turn with
no creatures on the
field, then when the turn
returned to the player
with Rift Bolt, they
had no choice
but to direct
the spell at themselves or
one of their creatures.
Again, it was
n't fun at all.
So, while it's great
that players now have the
choice of whether to play
cards with
suspension or not, it's
very important to
keep this
nuance in mind.  When the
last
time token is removed and you
decide not to
cast a
spell, it
remains
in exile forever.  You will
not get another chance
to play this card, and there is
currently no way to
add a time token to it again
to
activate the effect again
.  So what do we think
about this rule change?    Be
sure to
like if
you learned something new,
and subscribe if
you like the
suspension cards.
See you in the
next video.